je pense qu'on peut toujours aller plus
loin je pense que j'ai cette énergie à
trouver quelque chose qui va faire que
l'image va rester iconique non non aux
questions de notre
collaboration
je suis pas des photos je raconte des
histoires juno secondes plus tard je
suis parisienne et je pense que ça se
ressent donc s'il est dans le style mes
photos c'est pas facile de quitter le
paris vous devez déposer votre couronne
sur problèmes sociaux photographers
système comme toi
28 28
je me suis jamais considérée comme une
artiste j'ai une vie très calme le père
de mes enfants au bout de 30 ans d'être
ma fantaisie aller dans les photos de
mode
oui et à 0 pour le canadien
cela jamais relâche pas voilà les
épidémies la ville respecte
c'est le roi mage
d'ouyahia
imagine